this is jaco podcast number 118 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening
I need a mission we all need a mission
that's what life should be is a mission
that's what gives your life purpose and
focus and drive and ultimately
satisfaction
now that mission can be the job you work
at it can be providing for your family
or it can be getting better at jujitsu
or stronger at Olympic lifting or
starting a business that you want to
grow and build and take over the world
and sometimes people ask me what to do
if they don't know what their mission is
or what their mission should be and I
tell them if they're in that situation
to go help someone gonna help someone
else make that your mission because that
will make you better and it'll make the
world better and eventually from that
you'll see what your mission is now I
was lucky because from a young age I had
a mission I wanted to be some kind of
commando and eventually I ended up
hearing about the SEAL Teams and decided
that that was the best place for me and
that's where I went and once I got to
the SEAL Teams I had a new mission which
was to prepare for war and that's what
we did and then eventually
war came and then that was the mission
to take the fight to the enemy to close
with and destroy them through close
combat and that's what we did
but eventually for me and for everyone
in the military it ends maybe because of
retirement or maybe because of family
obligations or maybe for medical reasons
but for every warrior eventually the war
ends and that career ends and that
mission ends and I've talked a lot on
this podcast about how important it is
to find a new mission once the war is
over for you and you've done your part
you have to find a new mission well
tonight we have a guest on who pursued
much the same mission as me for as long
as he could and who has now found a new
mission that he is on so Dan Crenshaw
welcome to the podcast thanks jack oh
it's a pleasure to be here with you real
honor thanks for coming on and let's
just start at the beginning a little bit
for people that don't know who you are
let's talk a little bit about I guess
we'll talk about Katy Texas and at the
same time also include Ecuador and
Colombia about your childhood
absolutely well like you said I grew up
in Katy Texas I'm at six generations a
Texan flowing through me my dad's side
of the family and my dad was in the oil
and gas industry our whole lives
so when you hear things about Ecuador
and Colombia and even Egypt and Scotland
that says all the places we lived over
the years because it is uh because of
his career everybody and anybody in the
oil and gas industry in Texas knows that
it's a pretty common theme you know I
like to talk about some of the
challenges that I went through from an
early age and what kind of what drove me
or maybe and maybe drove my that that
capacity' pass 'ti that you need to
become a seal and um you know that
started with my mother and my mother got
uh diagnosed with breast cancer when I
was five years old and she fought it
hard for five years and she never quit
she never complained and never saw and
if she did I never saw it and if she
just took care of me and my brother
every day right up until the end man she
eventually lost that battle when I was
10 years old in 1994 but she instilled
in me you know what I what I think are
American and Texas values of integrity
respect and just never quit never quit
no matter what and don't feel sorry for
yourself because she never did she truly
never did and she asked where she told
me before she died that I would soar to
great heights and I don't know what that
meant at the time but I think we know
now and not long after that you know
when I could start reading books and and
and grab the first Navy SEAL dick
Marcinko novel Rogue Warrior like if
your book wasn't out yet otherwise maybe
oh yeah Rogue Warrior that that that
came out when I was already in yeah a
matter of fact it came out right as I
showed up at the team's it I'm pretty
sure that's right when it came out and
obviously created some turmoil and the
teams but it was pretty interesting
especially cuz I knew guys that had
worked for for dick Marcinko
that was pretty interesting to talk to
them and and to be totally frank with
you
most of the guys that work for dick
Marcinko loved him and and as a matter
of fact one of the couple of guys that I
respect met there's one guy as a matter
of fact that that I work for and this
was a couple years later as a matter of
fact it was around 1994 because I was in
a seal platoon and and I was talking to
this guy that had worked for for dick
Marcinko and I said hey you know how was
dick Marcinko how was it to work for him
he looked at me said best CEO ever yeah
and this was from a guy that I have
utmost respect for so I thought that was
pretty cool even though you know his
book you know the book is it's I'd say
it's a Hollywood ish book yeah and and
you know the statement in there that
everyone always laughs about in the
teams is the statement that every seal
on his team could benchpress 500 pounds
right number K rolling we're not going
we're not even gonna make it realistic
we're not gonna make it realistic we're
just going straight to 500 pound
everyone on the team right and that's
just patently untrue and what sucks is
when you do that with that thing well
then you then people start looking to
booking on well what is true and what is
not right so and although from the way
it's been described to me the events in
that book a lot of them are compiled so
like this little thing happened on a
training event and this thing happened
on a training event and this thing
happened on training event but they'd
all be compiled into one big story and
yeah so it's kind of like a Hollywood
yeah it's a book it's a it's a
nonfiction ish for a ten-year-old Ben
Crenshaw didn't know that no problem
yeah yeah wouldn't be here without that
series of books and frankly you know I
probably still have two eyes but nobody
that's two eyes that's that's a luxury
yeah we'll get to that in a little in a
little bit so yeah I mean that you know
once you've once that and you know this
most seals operate this way or at least
they have the same story of yeah it was
from a young age I had a mission I knew
what it was and every decision I made
from from then until the moment I got
into buds was was was just
therefore that now when you did you I
know you lived overseas where'd you go
to high school so it must a high school
in Colombia okay
yeah and what did you play sports down
there I played soccer okay yeah Colombia
so kind of like what they had it was
that or volleyball
I could play volleyball and then you
applied from college from Colombia yeah
yeah okay this is this is kind of an
important question cuz a lot of people
ask me this question all the time you
were definitely wanted to be a seal what
made you make the decision between going
to college and you ended up going to
Tufts yeah and then in Massachusetts so
at some point you said to yourself okay
I could enlist tomorrow and go to boot
camp and you know be a seal within the
year or I can go to college for four
years and you know then apply and I'll
be in an officer in a leadership
position I could ask that question all
the time for me when I was 18 years old
the answer was real easy like oh I can
be a seal within a year sign me up
yeah and and that's what I did and for
you you obviously took a different
approach and people ask me all the time
which one is better and I tell them that
there's advantages and disadvantages to
both of them but what made you decide
you're gonna go officer style from the
get-go maybe you know along with my
mission of being a seal my whole life
the the a similar mission of I wanted a
college degree as well and I wanted to
knock that out and and then you know I
wasn't well-informed enough to really
speak about the difference between
officer and enlisted back then like I am
now but I did want a leadership role it
was important to me based on what I'd
read and based on the movies I'd seen
that I was in a leadership role
did you see Navy SEALs was that not
that's my that's leaf baboons answer to
why you became a seals straight up
Charlie shields Charlie Sheen
I didn't just see it you know we had it
on all the time yeah you know so a
combination of wanting a leadership role
maybe knowing too
you know was I really ready at age 18
you know I knew I wanted it but I have
also I also wanted to be prepared yeah
and I was able to think ahead enough to
know that maybe I can't swim all that
great just yet let's we might need some
more practice
God made a bit but all but it was mostly
like it was mostly I'm gonna go to
college first dress that's been my life
path that's what I'm gonna do and so
that's what I did
and I ended up at Tufts University
mostly because of its international
relations program I was that was my
focus it was foreign affairs
international relations politics and a
nun did a minor in physics just because
but why not yeah that sounds like fun
yeah mechanics it's not you speak
Spanish obviously from from growing up
in Colombia to see are you fluent in
Spanish pretty fluent yet no it's kind
of little rusty but and you did ROTC at
yes was there any seals there like prior
seals that were instructors or anything
like that no well no there was at
Harvard so a lot of these guys doing
master's programs while we're doing ROTC
they're not attached to the unit but I
did have the opportunity to work with
some guys and you know just get that
mentorship you just this is the kind of
workouts you might want to be doing I
mean just the basics cuz you just have
no idea going into it do you think kids
over prepare for buds now I think it
depends on the kid I often mentor guys
who want to go through and you know that
sometimes they do focus a little bit too
much on especially things they're good
at yeah I'm running ten miles a day
they've kind of like a five-minute pace
I'm like stop running never run again
yeah yeah you're good at that move on to
the next thing
yeah you know focus on your weaknesses
it guys just don't understand a little
little basics I don't know if they over
trained I haven't worked with enough to
really know I talked to people and they
send me messages all the time and
they're on this two-year training
program to get ready for buds and I'm
like hey train for two months and then
go no it's not that hard if you played a
sport in college or have you played a
sport in high school and you can run
like you'll get in good shape there and
it's going to be a challenge but
eating around especially when there's a
war going on that you don't really want
to miss yeah like that's a big deal to
me you know and I tell these guys this
Wars not gonna last forever
and you know I showed up with the team
in 1991 just missed the first call
Florida and it's you know we I didn't
shoot my weapon at the enemy for 13
years and that's a long dry hard 13
years and so yeah you want to miss out
on that snow you don't one of my old
team guy buddies it was like 1971 and
and he live he thought the Vietnam War
was gonna end and he's down at the
Marine Corps recruiter saying I want to
be a door gunner and Huey it's it's
interesting that there's you you know
you always hear about the protesters and
whatnot mm-hm but there's kids that want
to fight oh yeah we do have a there's a
warrior class in America that I think we
should be proud of and it'd be proud to
be a part of because it's a good people
with good values and they want to do the
right thing for the country so you show
up the butts so you get we get done with
college colleges college right
is there anything particular you want to
say about College no okay cool
particularly want to hear about it and
show but buds and any issues at Budds
yeah you know I started my I started
with class 261 about Tuesday afternoon
of my first hell week my stress fracture
developed into a pretty noticeable
fracture and I got the old question are
you hurt or are you injured mr. krenshaw
and you really want to be injured
because you better not just be hurt
because then you're just quitting and I
was I was injured pretty substantially I
mean you know I mean who stress
fractures are pretty normal
injury and buds okay so you so when I'm
sitting there talking about people don't
prep enough you're like actually you
should prep more do you think you could
have run more preparing for bugs I would
have I ran plenty I would have I would
have focused a little bit more on
strength and conditioning you know
something I just didn't know how to do
back then
is what happens in buds is I mean you're
gonna go to failure you know you're
gonna go to failure no matter what your
it's gonna happen on the hour every hour
maybe every ten minutes all the time
so guys who over prepare they they're
they can't understand why they're
failing so much right and that that
messes with their head so maybe that's
what you mean by over preparing because
that's what I mean by like I think I
think guys get too confident in their
abilities and they just don't understand
why they're hitting a wall all the time
whereas like guys like me or just like I
just I just expected to suck so it's
really not a surprise but we're just
gonna keep trying no matter what and
just never quit and and quitting is
never an option the other problem is if
you over prepare it maybe it becomes an
option this isn't the case for everybody
but I see some of the best in shape guys
quit because it was just they were like
maybe it was an option for them like
maybe I'll make it maybe I won't but if
you you should never go into buds
thinking that way and that's why a lot
of guys who make it through I think have
this story that well I wanted to do it
since I was 10 years old so it was just
never an option for me to ever quit
so yeah you do need to prepare enough to
make sure your muscles when they do fail
aren't putting all the strain on your
joints are that's what happened to me
because it just happened over time and
over time you're limping a certain way
and that just that causes a fracture
eventually because there's too much
pressure being put on your bones
so you know or I just had weak genetics
yeah just like my story really answer so
I got rolled back I came back again with
two 6-4 and you know you know you know
there's the that 2 mile run you doing
hell week
it's like Tuesday or so FL week and it's
a time I went through a long time well
it's like a Tuesday or something it's a
time to run and if you and if you get in
the top 5 you don't have to do it again
and then everybody else has to do it all
over again you get to rest under a boat
and you know eat sand or whatever they
let you do much on that sand over there
and you know my first whole week I was
dead last I mean just way be like not
even close right because I was limping
the whole time in my second hell week I
was I was first placed by maybe five
minutes you know and maybe because I
knew what the game was but everybody
does actually
the word gets around you know the it's
but it was it was it was a message maybe
to myself of like we're gonna we're
gonna not only do this but we're gonna
crush it and I'm gonna feel good about
it I'm gonna rest under that bone eat
mice and well everybody else is running
frankly it was really cold so I kind of
wish I'd been running at the time but
whatever I want the closest story I have
to that is we got done with a four mile
timed run and when we got done the
people that failed and I didn't fail but
there was a bunch of people that failed
and the instructor who is a really a
perfect instructor meaning that his
attitude and the way he carried himself
was epic four buds and he was the senior
chief of the phase it was dive phase and
the guys come across and he's collecting
the guys that fail which was probably at
least half the class and then you know
he says because I'm fair I'm gonna go
ahead and let you do this timed run
again get on the line ready go and
everyone had to run another four mile
time run right well not us but the
people that the people that passed got
to not know but the people that didn't
pass which was half the class had to go
and just run another four mile time to
run right then to see if they could then
pass it yeah much easier on the eighth
mile you're definitely doing a lot yeah
you put out as hard as you possibly good
for a four mile timed run which I
actually had to do every time I failed
to run and I failed one run in buds I
paced myself mm-hmm I said well you know
and I'll just paste myself I'm not gonna
put out as hard as I as a kind I'll save
a little bit for later and that didn't
work I I failed because I'm not a fast
runner and so from then on it was just a
sprint as hard as I could go for the
whole damn time yeah unlike you I didn't
win any races buds so you get done with
and you show up so now it's 2000 and
what what your is it this is 2007 okay
yeah 2007 yeah finishing buzz 2007 and
then moving to NS QT that's right lace
babban putting me through ROTC nice you
know I think I was I was I was
indoctrinated early on right on
bruiser stories
that's awesome and then from there you
rolled to team three team three and I
was team three with Fallujah in 2008 and
then back within Ramadi in 2010 with
trial platoon you know yeah your little
troop
you know going back to lay front in that
course it was interesting because what
that course used to be was almost like
an administrator course hey here's how
you write evals and they had a little
tiny bit of dashing zuv of tactics in it
but it was here's how you read write
evals here's you how you write Navy
messages and just that kind of stuff
yeah and you know we knew that these
kids needed to train because in Ramadi I
had guys that were first Platoon guys
out Ground Force commanders and we
wanted to make sure these guys knew what
to do on the battlefield and it was
awesome that life went there and started
rehashing that program and did a great
job I think it was very valuable yeah
yeah and yeah so then you got done with
that then you showed up a team three and
you went right on deployment right I
mean team three was already on
deployment so they they just deployed
you know and you know how that goes um
it's the the cycle of graduates so we
met up with team three I was in Fallujah
for a little while I was down in Basra
for a few months and actually stayed on
deployment to meet up with Team five and
and and helped them transition you know
as we were setting up another debt out
there in Basra great great first
deployment and learned a lot and got to
work a little bit and then came back to
Iraq in 2010 and another great
deployment for me because I was able to
take over as platoon commander when my
platoon OIC had to go to relieve another
platoon oh I see so you know we were
going through the entire targeting cycle
working with multiple Iraqi partners
throughout Ramadi and throughout all of
Allen bar we got to operate throughout
the entire province and even a little
bit in Baghdad so just an amazing
experience for a young Jo who wouldn't
normally be put in that position and
working with some of the best people
I've ever met you know we talked about
before I won't name names on the podcast
but you know well you're oh I see was it
was a great guy that got moved that's
why you got moved and obviously they had
confidence in you
you to move you up into the platoon
commander position which is an
interesting thing I had a group of
business people and they they there was
a guy that kept saying well no one can
take my place you know and then he was
surprised that he wasn't getting
promoted and you know explain to people
if you don't have a person below you in
the chain of command or two or three
people below you in the chain of command
that can take your job well then you're
gonna have to stay in your job and
you're not gonna get promoted yeah so
that that's that's proof that you're oh
I see like I said who's a great guy
actually he supposed to come on the
podcast at some point but he's a great
guy and he had groomed you and taught
you everything he could do and and made
you ready and trusted you to say when
when the boss came to him and said hey I
gotta fire a guy I'm gonna move you over
to Afghanistan is your is your a OIC
ready to take over and he could calmly
say yes he is and that's that's awesome
and that shows that he was a great
leader too to kind of prepare you
properly for that situation that's a
good point I mean that it's that is part
of leadership and management it's making
sure that below you and above you is
squared away yeah I would put it and I
would do that when I was running
training I would always kill you know
theoretically or what does it virtually
kill the four majors yeah all of us the
end sometimes I'd kill all of you yeah I
remember yeah there'd be some some
somebody carries happening for extended
distances yeah I was a little bit I was
a little bit crazy at that point and you
know I was good training yeah yeah you
know it's I was coming home from Ramadi
and I wanted to make sure you guys were
ready to ready for the worst possible
case scenarios you know so then you get
so you do that you finish out that
deployment that was a solid deployment
you were you were running a bunch of
stuff that that sounds like a good deal
now what you do when you came back so we
came back moved over to Support Activity
one and as you know they they run
intelligence support operations for the
SEAL Teams it's a fairly normal
transition to make as an officer and for
a lot of listen guys too but with that
ended what
really what that translated into is back
on deployment 2012 with my platoon again
SEAL team 3 trial attune and Kandahar
province so on that deployment this was
one of our more kinetic deployments and
it's it's Afghanistan it's Kandahar's
IEDs everywhere I mean everywhere I mean
to the point where you know our our
TTP's or our you know MRSA MRSA or SOPs
our standard operating procedures were
hey we're on patrol we're getting shot
at don't even move don't even go look
for cover because as soon as you move
you hit an IEE D I mean they're there
they're just they're that prevalent
throughout the entire ground not just on
pathways not just in doorways in the
most random of places these guys are
just burying these things and a woman a
whim you know and then it's and it's
chaos out there and we know they're not
that great at shooting at us so would
rather just take it so I'm gonna take a
moment just to emphasize what you just
said cuz it's really important and not
everyone will understand it the way you
the way you went over it quickly almost
from a tactical mindset so I just want
everyone understand what he said what
he's saying is when at this point the
IEDs were so bad that if you started
getting shot at by the enemy the obvious
and common and practice that everyone in
the world instinctively and by training
has is you immediately hit the ground
and seek cover and you get behind a log
do you hit behind a piece of terrain you
find somewhere to hide from the bullets
that are coming at you and what Dan
saying is during this deployment the
ided threat was so high that when the
enemy started shooting at them instead
of finding cover to hide from the
bullets they would rather just stay put
probably take a knee but not dive behind
something because the likely there's a
likely chance that there was an AED
there yep that's that's crazy it is this
you know we've all I've seen multiple
guys get get blown up and usually our
partners our Afghan partners who are
patrolling with us because you know
maybe they're just not as careful or
maybe they're the equipment they're
using to detect IEDs in the ground they
weren't using it properly whatever the
case may be or maybe just because it's
bad luck and they're just everywhere you
know it's and there's more yet more
Afghan partners than Americans oh by far
we would sometimes go in operations with
about a hundred Afghans and maybe 1215
seals yeah because that we're doing
entire clearance operations through
villages you know where we're going
house-to-house or shaking hands a little
bit of shaking hands it's a little bit
of on security you know
either defending ourselves or going on
the offensive it depends on the
situation
but you know we round everybody up we
talked to them you know we have we meet
with village elders so it's it's it's
it's a little bit of your your your I
guess your more typical and conventional
warfare tactic so we're trying to meet
and greet the population while also you
know being prepared for battle and and
but the hardest part of that was
certainly the iad threat you know only
single file lines everything we ever
learned in training of different
formations and you know staggered exelon
whatever it is it doesn't apply at all
it all gets thrown out the window
because it's it's only about single file
what has been cleared what hasn't been
cleared and you could you could veer
from that a little bit depending on what
area you're in in Kandahar and with more
mountainous areas less IEDs but even
then I've got a story you know these
guys some of our guys take a take a
point let's take it on the high ground
and a little hilltop I mean just in the
middle of nowhere I mean middle of no I
can't emphasize this enough it is the
middle of nowhere right and they sit
down and this pop goes off it was a
blasting cap that went low order which
means it didn't blow up the main charge
like a fifteen twenty pound charge I
would have killed all three of them
right then and there and I mean I want
to say that again middle of nowhere
there was no reason for there to be an
IE D right there but there was this was
out in the mountains and this wasn't
even in the the pen you know the
southern Kandahar district which it was
which is truly just a minefield
everywhere you know so you know the
can't emphasize how bad the threat is
there and even even even taking that
even taking a small high ground because
in behind a rock you know this is what
we could kind of things we ran into and
so that was that deployment it was a lot
of fun and uh but it was it was a hard
one for us you know on month six about
six months and it was June 15 2012 I was
hit by an ID blast by one of these you
know again they're everywhere
it was it was the one day we spent in
Helmand province so we went to Helmand
on a last-minute mission to support some
marine special operations forces out
there and as the early you know we
always fly in about the middle of the
night we do that so that the enemy can't
arm the IADC the IEDs are everywhere but
they're not always armed and if they if
they keep them armed they run out of
batteries and they don't work anymore so
they so there's there's a little bit of
tactical consideration there but you
know and it was the early morning hours
come and then the daylight starts to hit
we start to move around and we start to
clear out this one compound and hadn't
been totally cleared yet and one of my
Afghan interpreters was responding to a
call runs in front of me and completely
gets dismembered by about 15 pounds of
explosives underneath them and all I
know is I got hit with something kind of
feels like you're getting hit by a truck
while a bunch of guys in the truck or
shooting you with a shotgun that's sort
of what it feels like and you know I
mean my immediate reaction was feel my
legs
right so I feel my legs and everything's
still there you know I know something is
wrong distance from the IUD a couple
feet I mean it's so I mean because you
know Leah a few feet were you and me are
probably is about you know just across
the table and you know lots of pain pain
everywhere but not in my eyes so I was
completely blinded but you know totally
under the assumption that I just had
dirt in my eyes and I remained under
this assumption that there was really
nothing wrong with my eyes for frankly
for weeks to come and we'll talk about
that but you know I I was I didn't lose
consciousness I knew what was happening
I could hear
the moans everybody thinks that when
somebody gets their legs blown off
they're screaming like in the movies
it's just never the case it's a very
different like visceral sound of pain
and it's and I've heard it many times
now because this happened to us a couple
times and so I heard that I knew I knew
that Rahman had been hit cuz I could
hear him and you know one of our one of
my teammates tells a story where he got
hit with a the foot in a building next
door I mean and it was and that's how
they knew something had gone terribly
wrong and you know the medics come to me
there's nothing they can do for me
they sort of just wrap up my eyes they
know something's wrong I really don't
frankly I just I keep assuming there's
just dirt in my eyes and that it'll be
fine and eventually we get taken out of
there and I was able to get up and walk
to the helo because you know you don't
let somebody carry you when they've got
a firefight to finish and we get on and
as soon as the medics on the helicopter
see me they they put me out right away
and I don't wake up for days so when I
do wake up in Germany they they told me
my right eye had been removed and I'd
probably never see again out of my left
eye but there's a chance and again kind
of self-deception kicks in I'm like so
you're saying there's a chance we'll be
fine just get the surgery done get me on
a plane to back to Maryland to the
Walter Reed Hospital where these
surgeons are and let's do this and
they're like it's gonna be a day or two
I argue we argue you know that's how it
goes for the next couple days I can't
really move I can't get up to use the
bathroom my body is completely swollen
and and and company shredded really I
mean there's no real permanent injuries
to the rest of my body but it's it's in
such a state that like yeah just just
shock wave from the blast
I think shock and I was I had a ton of
shrapnel just throughout I think I was
swollen might have been muscle atrophy
from being in a medically induced coma
for so long because I'd been there been
that way for five or six days but really
couldn't move I mean just wrapped up
really tight because I mean is he's just
scarring a little bit
I was just was kind of been through a
meat grinder a little bit and I was also
I was hallucinating wildly so I
everything I saw was Afghanistan I was
lucid I understood what was around me
but all I could see was an Afghan guy
sitting next to me or an Afghan village
it was it was it's almost like phantom
pain but with your eyes and there's a
medical term for that I can't remember
but it was it's just an odd and
terrifying experience because it wasn't
I knew it wasn't real but it's just
everything I saw and eventually got back
to Maryland on a one on one of our
medical flights and you know my wife was
there waiting for me and you know we
began had that conversation about okay
what's the next surgery because I had to
remove the cataract I mean that was that
was the issue there was a lot of
shrapnel in my left eye though I that
was still there and you know the the
issue was could we can we safely remove
the cataract and will he ever see again
if we do do that what's what are his
chances really of having decent vision
and you know we we prayed and we and I
look back on it and again that you know
we call it self deception but it was
really the strength to stay sane and and
believe that I was actually going to see
again and I truly believe that was God
strength is working through me it was
allowing me to believe in something
impossible because otherwise I would
have gone nuts because people sometimes
ask me what's it like not knowing if
you're ever gonna see again
and I always answer I I don't know I
don't know what that's like because it
was never that was never my mental state
my mental state was always it'll happen
it's just a matter of time and then I
can finally get back to my platoon you
know the the issue for me was like when
are we gonna do this you guys told me
six weeks all right let's schedule it
inhale it was insanity yeah that's
obviously when I hear this story I think
a Ryan job who was with me in Ramadi
Neela and he got shot in the face and
you know it was a similar situation
where you know clearly his his eye one
eye was gone but his other eye appeared
to be intact
and he could actually see after he got
wounded then he got put into a he could
see what was happening and and want into
the Gaza vac vehicle but you know they
put him into a medically induced coma
and when he woke up he couldn't see and
then it was the same type of thing that
they were telling you they were telling
him which is look there was some nerve
damage we're not sure and his attitude
was very similar of like well it'll be
okay and you know it'll come back but
you know what didn't take very long
before the doctors were like no no um
it's it's it's not coming back and I
forget the timeline you know I forget
the timeline because it's kind of a kind
of a blurred together but yeah for him
it was he had a great attitude but you
know at the end it didn't happen yeah
and you know and that's a guy that was
still like and he also still wanted to
come back and get back with his platoon
and was telling me you know don't worry
I can smell the enemy and I'll know
where to shoot let me back sir so yeah
the the fact that you were able to
recover is awesome awesome and you know
it's uh it shows it should show people
that you know even though you had a
great attitude
the threat of of never being able to see
again was very very real very very real
oh yeah and it truly was I mean we had
miracles occur in the operating room
multiple occasions and doctors were just
amazed that not only could I see again
but see well again it was because
they're in their minds they're like well
if we do the surgery and his retina
doesn't detach like we think it might
he'll still have you know crappy vision
you know because his cornea is all
destroyed I mean everything's a mess in
this eye and you know we'll get him some
decent glasses so we can kind of live
his life but he's pretty much
permanently disabled and I just didn't
listen I don't even remember these
conversations like I think I blocked him
out
and you notice because the first surgery
was we've got to remove the cataract
okay that went well
all right we moved the cataract great
you know and the next step is to put a
lens implants in your eye like like
anybody normally would only have
cataract surgery that's just a normal
thing to do
we ended up never doing that because
it's kind of like replacing a windowpane
on a normal eye but if the frame of the
window is completely destroyed then you
have to so the windowpane took curtains
and that's never a good policy so they
eventually refused to do that on me even
though I was demanding it constantly but
because I wanted to see again I wanted
to get back and I don't want about big
fake glasses which is what I have to
wear now or or this specialized contact
but then another problem occurred which
is a hole in my retina that was
expanding an event and this is again
it's kind of a normal you know if you're
over 50 this might be a normal thing
that occurs and then you have a pretty
routine surgery to get rid of it and to
stop it but for me it was incredibly
fragile but we had to do it so I went
blind again for six weeks recovering
from this surgery so you know I was I
was truly living in darkness for a long
time you know and not always thank God I
wasn't hallucinating the entire time
that stopped after about week one you
know just or just after my major surgery
my first major surgery but I went blind
again and another miracle happened
because they truly thought I wasn't
gonna make it through that surgery
either so after when they when you were
blind again for six weeks going into
that did they tell you okay you're gonna
be blind for a period of time it's yeah
take time yeah yeah II just yet because
of the recovery process you they put a
gas bubble in your eyes so that it puts
pressure on the back here retina and you
have to be face down for six weeks it's
just the weirdest what the hell did you
do for six weeks
oh my gosh down I bet I got one of those
massage chairs uh-huh
where you know plant your face down and
I had audiobooks going all day long it
was great yeah and by great I mean not
great at all yeah by great you mean
awesome yeah yeah
Starbucks and so you you you had to stay
facedown all the time are you and that
six weeks goes by and then they
eventually remove the gap
bubble and dissipates yeah so there's
eventually a point where you're like
okay it's gone now I can I'm allowed I'm
allowed to look straight again and then
and then it's just you know refitting
your eye with the right eye where you
know my glasses in contact so I can
actually get back to our normal life and
in frankly that took years it you know
it's I eventually I'll just I'll skip to
the end about two and a half years and I
finally got got a referred by the Navy
to an outside clinic that does these
these amazing contacts there's only one
company in the world that does it and I
can see 20/20 with it no not up close
you know my visions complicated because
I have a cataract but but I actually see
20/20 vision a distance which is let me
just not even close to what they thought
was possible
so in but despite all that I mean I
before that two and a half year mark I
still had decent enough contacts to
survive I mean they just weren't
comfortable they kind of drove me crazy
and you know all I cared about was
getting back to the team I was almost
going back to team three the the command
wouldn't let that happen in the end
there's because I couldn't get the
medical waiver to do it so I stayed at
what was now is called special
reconnaissance team one again we do
Intel support for the SEAL Teams and did
a troop commander there so in charge of
about 50 personnel a mix of seals
intelligence specialists all sorts of
really great people that you know as you
know support the teams and intelligence
matters and deployed to Bahrain worked
with Joint Special Operations Task Force
Scout they're working you know all
throughout the Persian Gulf working on
classified programs they're working in
Lebanon as well and coming back from
that told I had to eventually get out I
mean that I had to start the medical
retirement process but before before I
did I truly I wanted to serve again I
mean it was it was extremely important
to me so this deployment to Bahrain was
about 2014 by the time I was really told
I had to medically retire was around
2016 but you know this process takes up
to a year and I asked that I you know be
able to serve again in some capacity let
my let my the specialties that I'd that
I had
I heard over the years at SRT one be put
to use in the Pacific so they deploy me
to Korea for my last deployment in the
end of 2016 and as soon as I got home
from that I was I was medically retired
and had to find my next mission you know
like you talked about the earlier on in
the podcast I mean it's it life truly is
about mission and you know I'm getting
into politics now running for Congress
and in Houston Texas for the second
district and I talk about this a lot and
from a from a political philosophy
standpoint if you don't give people a
mission or you don't encourage people to
find their purpose and their dignity you
you have a failing Society it's so
important and you're not you know even
even think tanks talk about this like
American Enterprise Institute like our
policies need to promote a sense of
mission for people and how people
understand they have value in this world
they're here on this earth for a reason
and if you're not constantly seeking out
what that value is that you contribute
to society you're not doing your job and
we need to help you do your job if need
be but you but you do have value and you
and you must find that purpose in life
and in guys like us I think can't
survive without that constant mission
and well we see it all the time with
with all vets when they get I talk about
this all the time the vets that get out
that have a note I knew it another
mission they focus on that mission and
they go kick ass the vets that get out
and don't know what they're gonna do
that flounder around without a direction
those are the guys that end up in
trouble because they don't have a
mission so they go and drink a beer then
they have another beer and then the they
could get prescribed pain medicine for
their back which hurts which sucks and
and they go down this bad road and I
believe a lot of it is because you know
they just need that next mission but you
got done with so 2016 you didn't roll
right into politics you rolled to you
what you went back to college right I
don't know intentional politics did that
become dozen 16 did that become you you
looked at what you're gonna do next and
you said okay well how else can I serve
how else can I move forward what's my
next mission gonna be and you decide
you're gonna go back
school back to school for I knew I was
gonna stay in public service so I knew
my next mission was gonna still be
government I wasn't exactly sure what I
knew I wanted to do I wanted to be able
to implement policies and strategy and
take that tactical experience because I
had you know because I built an
understanding of what policy in DC looks
like on the ground and actually because
the reason I was hurt that day in 2012
was because of an Obama administration's
you know policy of always wanting boots
on the ground Battle of damage
assessments for any any close air
support
so because earlier in that day Marines
are called in close air support on a
compound they were taking fire from for
some reason they wanted guys to walk
across minefields and go take pictures
of it right that's not good policy now
it's not a victimhood story don't get me
wrong I mean there was a battle going on
we want it to go I don't care really
what the reason is but from a policy
perspective that's that's concerning
that that that kind of pressure is being
put on our to star and our and that's
what drove that mission that doesn't
make a whole lot of sense so it's great
to see somebody like general Madison
right now who says the opposite they
will not waste my troops time with these
kind of things and he's on record you
know after we dropped the mother of all
bombs while back it's on record saying I
will not waste my troops time going to
count the dead bodies out there that's
just good policy so you know I wanted to
take that experience to Washington the
the the natural and the national next
step was get the right education so the
Harvard Kennedy School of Government is
where I went got a master's degree in
public administration focusing more on
national security issues economic issues
and in a little bit of political so US
politics how long was that school I just
did a year one year program and you know
it's kind of the accelerated executive
style program that you can apply to if
you're if you're older and you actually
have some some life experience it's the
intensity level of that as tense as you
make it I took I took about four extra
credits more than I needed to so I was
busy because I you know it's it's not
like going to college we were just
getting through it I think I would
I recommend anybody you know you do a
master's degree later on in life you're
really gonna get the most you can out of
it you because you care about learning
you're there for a reason because you
have purpose and you know why you're
there so I got a lot out of it honestly
it was it was quite it was a really an
amazing year I mean you hear from the
greatest people and you know Bush's
deputy national security adviser
teaching us I had you know the the
premier experts on counter-proliferation
policy teaching us in classic Reagan's
chief economic adviser is my economics
professor I mean you just can't you know
these people don't speak in terms of
like this is what we think happens in
the White House during no they're like
when I was in the White House this is
how it got done I mean that's the kind
of the level of instruction that you're
getting so I was really happy to get
that education and it it it's truly
applies to as in my current role as
running for office I'm glad I was there
but but I hadn't necessarily thought
about running for office even after I
graduated I was looking at more policy
jobs you know because I didn't I don't
have the political connections I don't
have the background and money and the
donor networks to really to jump off on
a campaign right away
and we thought about it in the long-term
sense for sure but but not in the short
term and I was working with Pete
sessions congressman Pete sessions on
Capitol Hill for a while getting
legislative experience there and working
doing some consulting and eventually
came to a head where I was about to take
a job either doing counter weapons of
mass destruction policy for Department
of Defense or go run for office because
my congressman ted poe had just
announced retirement and we prayed about
it we thought about it we had the right
backing from you know some
well-connected people that i think god
just put in front of us at the right
time and my wife and i went for it you
know she was she was all in it was all
in and and that was it I mean I've
already I would already come back to
Texas by this point to help with
Hurricane Harvey reconstruction was out
volunteer and we're in my old hometown
of Katie
my parents didn't flood they were they
were livid living in spring which is
just north of Katie for the past 13 14
years but you know
was needed help neighbors still need
help it's it's still pretty devastated
in Houston and you know that I think the
decision became easy that we knew this
was the right choice like this was the
right mission if I cared about nuclear
proliferation policy what better place
to affect it to them from Congress I
care about helping flood victims no
better place than elected office if you
care about border security you know
which Texans do no better placed in
public office you know if we care about
protecting Americans and protecting the
the the sanctity of the SEAL Teams and
pushing the right policies from the
defense level then you know elected
politics is where I can do it from and
and so the decision was easy it was it
was the right choice for us we knew we
were doing it for the right reasons we
know we are still doing it for the right
reasons and we're not gonna quit so with
all those things that you said that are
real positive about having a political
career yeah you must have also been
looking at the the nightmare gut-check
just mudslinging that you're gonna have
to go or that's gonna be thrown at you
and all that and your family getting the
microscope on them and watched all the
time and no privacy and all that how did
you weigh those things out and did you
think about those things as well
absolutely and it's it's by far the most
concerning thing about politics I mean
if anything drives drives you out it's
it's that you know and frankly the
experience hasn't been too bad yeah I
mean I get attacked for silly things
here and there I've got a you know one
of my opponents or what I would call one
of his cronies
I think there's these there's these
corrupt but they call them the slates
in Harris County which is Harris County
is Houston
and these three slates are essentially
three political mailers that go out and
they make they they target senior
citizens especially and they make it
sound like there's these these these
conservative review type of magazines
you know these something with authority
behind it but really they're not really
they're pay to play and it's just one
author and they pick who they like based
on what kind of money they were able to
get out of the deal
and then they trash everybody else so
you know they put mine in they put my
bio on there doesn't say anything about
who I actually am it just says I'm
homeless and don't have a job and would
like to pick I mean it's it's absurd
right and most people read it and they
think this is this this can't be serious
so and actually it got me a lot of votes
because people would look me up after
that it's like oh well this is this is
who this guy is maybe I will vote for
him after all but but unfortunately
that's politics and that's that's the
world we live in even though the you
know the Harris County Republican Party
has publicly denounced these so-called
slates because they send out these voter
guides and you know they denounced them
but people don't always know people
aren't you know sometimes a lot of folks
still rely on those so you're battling
this kind of corruption you're battling
this establishment I mean you know we
always talk about the establishment in
politics and I don't really knew what
that meant I think until I saw behind
the curtain and now I truly understand I
mean it's this class of politically
connected people and in the donor class
that really just stick together and it's
nothing to do with policy we're doing
the right thing for the American people
it's just how much money do you have
that's all that matters and it's not
it's not all that matters we made it
into the runoff after last week's
election which was March 6
there was nine candidates in my primary
and on an election day I came out far
and away first place we beat out overall
in the election I was second place but
we beat out so just to again explain
that a little bit for people that aren't
paying attention to the election you
were in the in the fight you're going
against nine other candidates going into
the election obviously there's some
people that vote early through mail
voting and they just vote early and you
were behind there but then as your
campaign picked up and people started to
actually see who you are when people
came to vote on Election Day
you you won election day but you didn't
win all the votes combined because the
people that had very early and were not
that correct and it shows the trajectory
and the momentum of what you're doing
right we've got some great momentum that
were excited about and even put in do
paint a broader picture you know we
started this late November and the
election was March 6 that's that's a
very
little time for anybody to get a
campaign together so and we're going up
against one of my opponents had probably
will have ended up spending when the
numbers come in between six and seven
million dollars which is a record for
self funding for a campaign like this
another opponent you know similar
similar very high spending very much
self-funded and was already a state
representative so had some kind of
campaign machine in place you're trying
to catch up you're trying to build a
campaign team in a in a message within
almost no time at all and no money
whatsoever that's it's not an easy task
in only a couple of months usually you
start like a year out if you're gonna
run for Congress but but this that just
wasn't the case here because Ted PO
announced retirement about mid-november
so we had a lot to overcome
we built that momentum quickly we worked
hard worked hard got the message out met
as many people as we could and you know
it worked we we've snuck by snuck out of
that third-place spot because as you
said so we were behind during early
voting and mail and voting because that
that stuff happens so early there was
just no way for my momentum to catch up
in time but by Election Day
we were far and away first place and
were able to sneak into the runoff so
now we're in the runoff and that's May
22nd so we got another you know two
months to to really prepare and and get
our message out there and I think we're
we're excited about it and I think it's
gonna go well
so you talked about this a little bit
you talked about money right money and
as disturbing as it is what's driving so
much of who wins these elections is is
who has the most money because that's
how you get the advertising that's how
you get the mailers that's how you get
the word out there I mean if you don't
have the money to pay for advertising
then no one knows who you are and you
don't get any votes so as disturbing as
that is you without money you you you
you have a real hard time I mean you've
done an amazing job with the limited
amount I mean how much money did you go
into that last election we spending
ended up spending total about $200,000
so we were outspent in a 30 over over 30
to one easily and I would you could say
more if you count whatever
else you know what the first and second
place also spent against me I mean you
know something to be proud of but so I
think you raised two hundred thousand
dollars and you went up against somebody
that spent six million dollars right and
yeah like I said unfortunately money
drives so much of these elections and
that's why you end up with those people
that I mean I know you can't
well technically or possibly but you're
not supposed to be able to buy an
election right right but I mean the the
the person that you talk about that
spent six million without that money I
mean we're we're would is a female right
and where would she have been without
spending that money leading I'm assuming
she wouldn't have it anywhere no she was
able to buy herself at least third place
right and maybe if she had another more
money she would have been able to buy
herself first place that's a scary
thought it is I mean it you know I I
don't like the way campaign finance
works I don't think you should build a
self fund that much for a race and you
know I understand that there's some good
arguments to make that you can self-fund
you know over what the individual limit
is but but to that extent I mean it's
you know it truly creates a donor class
of politicians and like that's just I
don't think that's what we want is
American people and it's it's up but
it's up to voters in the end to decide
it's up to voters to see through that
and you know I always encourage go out
and do your research you know just just
do enough to go on the websites of each
candidate and get a feel for who they
are watch them watch their videos see
how they speak see how they would
represent you see how they would
articulate your values you know we put
up YouTube videos all the time you can
always watch me in interviews coming or
listen to podcasts listen to Jacko's
podcast and it because you want people
to get to know you and you need to be
out there with folks you need to be
meeting people everywhere you go and
that's how we want you know that's how
we built that connection with the voter
that's how we built momentum just
getting out and meeting people and
inspiring them and connecting with them
that's that's that still works and we
proved that that's one of the things
that you did while your opponents were
spending a bunch of money you put on
your
shoes yeah and ran through your entire
district right I did I limped a lot of
the way too because we talked about over
preparing well sometimes you can under
prepare and when you're running a
campaign there's not a lot of time to
get your running in and so I started
that hundred mile run and it was going
well you know so I want to back up a
little bit we we plan this awhile out it
was gonna be five days run across the
whole district really show that
dedication I want to I want to get on
the ground I want to show the dedication
to every inch of this district and with
whatever publicity we get out of it
we're gonna use it for a good cause and
we set up a GoFundMe account it's still
active if you want to donate to it let's
go fund me.com slash rebuild Houston
with Dan Crenshaw and that money goes to
three particular volunteer groups that I
was able to identify and vet they're
still out there every day rebuilding
people's homes is that I mean that is
still going on I always try to let
everybody know if you're a contractor if
you've got any expertise please come
volunteer in Houston we are backed up
into it you know it is it is tough to
find a contractor these days even if
people have the money to pay for it they
still can't get any availability the
demand is so high that the prices have
gone way through the roof we need more
people there nationwide so you know
please come to Houston there's work for
you and there's good work there's a lot
left to do and people need it so and
these volunteer groups are out doing it
you know four five seven thousand
dollars between five and seven thousand
dollars they can rebuild a whole home
because all their labors free rights
volunteers and they they do a great job
and they're working in a lot of these
neighborhoods where were individual just
can't do it themselves and it was it was
just great to see that a lot of church
affiliated groups always out there
helping and you know it makes you proud
to be a tax it makes me proud to be an
American so we finished that run you
know by by day three it was certainly
limping through most of it
it changed out my shoes day five or
running pretty well again but it was
tough enough but it was it was fun it
was great it was a great experience
you see people honking at you maybe
because you're in their way maybe
because maybe because they're supporting
you I don't know but I mean it was just
it was it was a pretty incredible
experience to see the supporters out
there to see just you know just it was
it was great
we went and that was that was when early
voting started it was we voted on day
one of that run and in you know two
weeks later on Election Day we wrapped
it up and it was it was a good night it
was a we're on pins and needles it
wasn't until 2 a.m. that we knew that
we'd actually come that come into second
place by 155 votes oh so do you think
anybody says their vote doesn't count
doesn't matter that's wrong it truly
matters I mean every single vote
mattered I can't thank every volunteer
enough can't thank every supporter
enough because a lot of people went out
and they maybe got 10 votes here and
there maybe 100 votes here and there you
know individuals were able to do that
and put us over the top because they
believed in the message they believed in
our candidacy and it was just you know
it's humbling and it's it's almost you
feel a weight of responsibility when
people put their trust in you like that
as you should feel it because you don't
want to disappoint them and you know you
you can't let your supporters down and I
truly feel that way about every vote so
what's so what's next right now well
we're the runoff the runoff is just mean
and Kevin Roberts and just you know it's
May 22nd early voting starts again a
couple weeks before that and it's a lot
of the same you know we we stick to the
basics we professionalize our
organization we asked for more money
please donate a crunch out for
congress.com
and we and we we so that that's actually
real though like you kind of you kind of
joke about it and I know you're like
like most good human beings you feel
uncomfortable saying hey give me some
money but the reality is for you to take
this to the next level that you need you
need money and and so when you say that
kind of jokingly that the reality is if
you don't get that money it's gonna be
really hard to swing an upset right and
so so that's what's the what's the
website its Crenshaw for congress.com
CREN sha WFOR congress.com
you can donate there you can check out
the candidacy there you know see our
interviews your YouTube videos or
commercials my bio everything it's all
in one spot follow us on Facebook we've
got a pretty exciting social media
presence that's how we get a lot of our
word out because you know it's cheap and
it hits the right
people so crunch off for congress.com
and you know that money we spend it
wisely it doesn't go to anything silly
it's you know we need it to send mail to
to voters you know to get our message
out we needed to put out radio ads we
needed to buy t-shirts for volunteers
and to buy yard signs so that people can
put them in their yards and create that
upwelling of support where everybody's
got a dan Crenshaw sign now that's
that's how we do it and it's just but
it's we work our butts off I promise you
that we work for we work for every vote
out there and I truly believe that's how
it should be and that's how I would be
in Congress yeah
that's awesome and I know you're on a
kind of a time schedule today and I know
you got some other things that you want
to do here while you're out here in
sunny sunny San Diego which isn't too
sunny today but I think we just hit
everything of how people can best
support your cause and obviously I'm in
Crenshaw for Congress on Twitter you're
Dan Crenshaw Texas TX correct
so at Dan Craig Crenshaw TX and then on
Facebook it's pretty easy to find you
it's just Dan Crenshaw and tough for
Congress at Crenshaw for Congress pretty
easy yeah I just searched Dan crunch on
you pop right up so that's that's it
well you know obviously I just want to
say before you take off thanks for your
service thanks for thanks for your
sacrifice for this great country thank
for what you've done for what you're
doing and thank you for what you are
going to do and appreciate everything
appreciate that Jack oh you know the
service isn't over you know we we find
our purpose we find our new mission and
and this is it for me you know it's it's
helping Texans it's given Texans a
representative I think they can be proud
of we are so often just disgruntled and
ashamed of our politicians and we don't
really think they're working on our
behalf because we don't always elect
people who truly put service before self
and and you know part of this campaign
is
it's convincing those that we do have a
future and we do have a future of
leaders that will attract people to
conservative values and and keep those
values alive and and again give us a
leader that we can be proud of awesome
well I think they'll definitely find
that with you thanks for coming on and
it's an honor to be here until you come
back on once you get the W once you get
the win come back on and you can explain
to us where you're going from there
absolutely how we did it get out and
vote may 22nd everybody thanks Dan
thanks for coming on thank you
so dan has left the studio but he's also
left some very good ways to support him
and what he's doing and echo Charles
mm-hmm
speaking of support yeah maybe you could
tell the troops how they can support
this cause sure if they want if they're
much if they want and and while they're
supporting this cause also supports
Thomas to himself which is important if
they want you know you what I just said
yeah very important I said important you
know you said it correct yeah two T's in
that one normally there's no T's in it
for me yeah yeah important kind of like
the British accent sometimes they don't
say the t's too and sometimes the same
really solid you know stink like they
say it's not back to reality they don't
say that reality or reality they see it
nonetheless back to support yeah if you
want to support support your joints this
is how you support your joints if you
didn't already chuck with supplements
good supplements krill oil super krill
Jocko super krill oil and joint warfare
supplements for you joints maintain them
also discipline pre-workout pre-mission
cognitive enhancer plus physical in
answer for
multiplier force multiplier yeah there's
layers yeah actually yeah you know it's
like a blend it's a good blend yeah um I
am running low on the krill oil I did
not take my own advice for the eruption
subscription yeah so it to manually get
some more but payment that's life
sometimes if you want to get on the
subscription thing re up every what is
it month right because it's a month
supply you can yeah yeah yeah however
much you take and that's the smart way
to do it totally is joint warfare too
yeah fully it's the one I think the
combo is the best way to go for sure
recommend the combo nonetheless you get
them at origin main comm good way to
support and support yourself that's a
big one also at origin main comm there
are Gea's and rash guards for you
jujitsu journey if you have chosen or
will choose to go on that jujitsu
journey there's no reason why not you
should go on the jujitsu yeah and if
you're gonna ask what if I'm small big
large overweight underwear younger young
the answer is start jujitsu yeah how do
you get in shape for jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu
yeah that's what you do yeah you know
Tim Tim always says like oh you know
he's been out of the jujitsu for a long
item forward yeah yeah and yeah I gotta
get back in shape too good no yeah
you're looking at the wrong lame huh
yeah you go back to jujitsu the juice to
get you in shape yeah you be you'll be
fighting this we're gonna something you
can suffer a little bit but might even
suffer a lot and probably a lot it's
already got to be hard mentally for a
guy like Timbo because he's a purple
belt yeah and so he's gonna come
engagement by some white belts I mean
not wipeouts by some blue belts yeah so
no belts cuz you know some blue belts
they bring it yeah and the key and they
can keep bringing in been in there yeah
yes so to be like come back and then and
it adds that level of anxiety cuz you
know when you feel yourself get well you
probably don't know this but if you feel
yourself gassing and you're like shoot I
knew I was gonna guess now you're really
gassy now the anxiety goes something yes
some more there's a how it is he'd want
to avoid all that stuff that's what I
think but you know that's when you put
all these weird expectations on yourself
my opinion in the jujitsu so just going
to do just and learn jujitsu and when
you do you're gonna want a ghee if you
do geek because you can do doggy as well
but when you choose Aggie I recommend
you recommend I think there's only one
recommendation I agree in all
seriousness there's only one
recommendation yeah and I've been
through a lot of geese I have a lot of
gay experience we'll see a significant
amount of experience and the origin he
has proven legitimately to be the best
one kind of by far - yeah there's this
one that I used to use it that was good
was fine and it was like good yeah
there's a difference though there's a
difference between this skis good yeah
and then you get an orange ngey yeah
right yeah you know it's funny like you
know how like when you get a new Gihon
rash guard or whatever and you're kind
of fired up a good train because you got
your new gear yeah you know it's that
it's that faster that feeling didn't
wear off like for a while did you feel
that like when we rolled when we were
both wearing new origins I did refire it
up yeah yeah did you think maybe was
gonna be the day for the record I always
think do you always think it's gonna be
the day always yeah does maybe one day
there we know that I just think it's
gonna be the day to maybe it's not tough
maybe a will I don't know could be the
day yeah anyway or gin main comm get
your guy there when you choose to get
Agee there's compression gear - rash
guards if you do know ghee there's rash
guards there - all made in America yeah
I was gonna say all made in America yeah
which is like it's no big deal no it's a
huge deal yeah it's a huge deal made in
America in Maine in our factory by
awesome workers and it's not the kind
where by crafts people perhaps craftsmen
craftsperson
craftspeople because man they're a
little more females yeah but they're
craftsmen yeah men doesn't mean you're a
man and me they're human
yeah as far as I know like modern man
like mankind mankind yeah yeah they look
so cross mankind crafts mankind
nonetheless all made in America yes and
that is a big deal and it's not the kind
where it's like yeah let's import all
our things or whatever and then we'll
quote-unquote make it in America where
you you take the one check box that it's
like yeah technically it's made it's not
that kind it's the kind where they grow
the content in America they what do they
do after they grow the cut in their
harvest harvest cotton they do well they
die the cotton and they weave the cotton
yeah yeah there's a whole bunch of steps
all done in America yeah donal end the
cotton because it's not just cotton it's
an athletic that's one of the problems
with the old geese they're all made just
with with cotton they're like like crap
yeah and then why would you not get
modern technology well why because they
don't have they don't do jiu-jitsu where
they're making the geese yeah now so
like little issues that come up in you
just little or big ones or whatever one
they come up in jail you don't know who
that you put a origin key in the dryer
it's dry like quick yeah and because
it's not all cotton yeah because if you
remember in the teams cotton kills sure
cotton kills cuz it gets wet and then
it's heavy and makes you cold jams you
up yeah it doesn't dry quick enough
mm-hm
get the blend going yeah then you're
good to go
there's all kinds of different weaves
too which is cool then let's go to or
Jemaine come you can check out whichever
one you want
hey if you want something get something
also what you want to do is go to the
emerging camp if you want so jiu-jitsu
emerging camp it's not like a training
camp for a TCC no it's an educational
experience yes like you immerse yourself
in that you can modulate to the level of
your personal commitment to getting
after it yes yes so some people will be
there and they're gonna be really sore
every day
okay they're gonna be getting after it
hard some people are gonna be brain
their brains gonna be some more sore
than their body because they're gonna be
more looking at it from the education
that they're Native learning new moves
and techniques yeah so that's what's
cool about the the immersion camp or
some of us
nothing's gonna be sore because maybe
it'll be sore for a little while and
then we're just gonna cruise a little
bit exercise the brain more and then the
body is thanking for do whatever you
like
yeah and there's a lot to go on and it's
kind of fun too that's the thing yeah
yeah well it's cool to hang out with
just a bunch of people that are gonna do
jujitsu for seven days yeah and then
then they get like five tons of knobs
and you don't have to stay there the
whole time yeah there's a there's a
there's a first part in a second part
you know it's like the first few days
and then you can do this the second few
days and then you can do all them if you
want so August 26 through September 2nd
yeah we're gonna be there you know who
else is going no big deal Dave Burke
yeah Dave Burke's got the bug yeah oh
yeah oh he's got the bug
yeah he'll call me for just like verbal
it like so he be texting me about about
like guard position some really hey
let's do it
communicate about guard passing via text
yeah
amen people with Americana yeah and it's
in an interesting conversation because
he says oh well the Americana is like
what I use the most right now and and I
told him like the Americana is actually
not a really effective move right
against anyone that has trained for a
little bit right purple belt you're not
gonna you might catch in him a blue belt
in Americana I'm probably belt probably
not gonna happen I did catch a black
belt in Americana the other day and and
it was like shame you know I got caught
with America yeah in this this
particular black belt was like shame you
know he he hung his head in shame music
yeah
but I explained to Dave though the
reason that the Americana is effective
for him right now the most effective I'm
like is it the first submission that you
learned yes it is so he's practiced at
the most and he's figured out all the
little nuance things that you haven't do
right in order to make the move a move
work and the the Americana work if so
he's figured out some of those things
because he's tried it a bunch even when
he missed it he learned something and
even know he learned something but he
learned something so he keeps trying and
he got good
he's good at the Americana you know he's
not going against people that know how
to defend it yet which is gonna be a
problematic so you got it you got a you
know that's what happens but isn't that
part of the whole learning process
though cuz the yes sink thing I mean
remember when I mean I'm assuming you
had similar experience where yeah sure
you do americanas and you'd get them oh
and their art moves for years like like
like for when I first started you my
first good move
was the Ezekiel the fact you know I used
to call it the easy kill the easy kill
yes he killed that's what I thought it
was one of oh but it was
I learned it like one of the first
submissions islet and I just tried it
all the time and I got pretty good at it
then you realize that it's not that hard
to defend the zekiel eventually when you
start going against better guys so then
you got to move to the I think the next
move that I actually started doing a lot
of was the Chimaera and I spent a couple
years at Chimaera and then I spent a
couple years at crucifix then I spent a
couple years at the straight full lock
then it you know so and you know Joe's
position yeah that's all but gave Burke
back to my point he's coming he's at
home under the the camp yeah and you
know who else is I won't see well it's
gonna come we'll see if we'll see if
Lafe yeah well you know we all have to
work sure yeah I locked this off though
yeah just sweet yeah it's really good
fun yeah cool oh man if you can make
that make that what's the date on them
again
August 26 through September 2nd oh yeah
and if you want it if you do want to
come you can go to origin man calm and
you go to the merchant camp and you can
sign up yeah you can come and hang out
it's a good lobster if you like lobster
yeah do you like long steak
yeah hang out in Maine visit our factory
you know which is awesome I think you
can go like paddling stand up stand up
to paddle in the loading stuff yeah all
kind of stuff yeah also a good way to
support yourself if you choose to vary
up your worked up make it a little less
boring you always make it sound like I
do these boring workouts yeah and I just
realized that and taking that abuse for
quite some time yeah my workouts are not
boring oh yeah the fact they're boring
and and hard so they're hard yeah here's
the thing we're what boring is like just
a complete matter of opinion you know
so to me if you're gonna do 20 reps
squats bra rest 20 reps rest 20 reps
until you're like that's it kinda boring
and have you ever done it before
yes you've done that we're not your
exact one but yeah I did do 20 reps
watch some in fact ya don't 20 reps
squats that you can only squat 10 times
well that's physically impossible but no
yes it is if you can only do 10 times
you don't do 10 times though you can do
it too many times you can do it 20 times
no that's it
that's not how it works all right hey
look take my word for it you can
physically do it 10 times
mentally you do it 20 times okay imagine
you do 20s okay so look you can
physically do it 10 times now I guess
technically you're right
and I want to listen I don't want split
hairs but you're still not right if you
can do it 10 times but you can do it 20
times because look if you can do
something 20 times you can do it 10
times so yes but what you're saying is
something that you you know max out at
10 times the weight you use to max out
at 10 times you do it 20 times
physically impossible
mentally impossible apparently for Echo
oh man see anyway back to the word maybe
that's where them skinny knees maybe
anyway if you wanna bury up the workout
go to audit calm slash y'all go get some
cool kettlebells yeah get some battle
ropes get a mace get two maces a heavier
one and a lighter one boom when I use
them so might my workouts are
interesting all right well there you go
you have an interesting workout we'll do
it that way that's what I that's what I
would would what do you say suggest okay
anyway good stuff in there don't get
addicted to the website because there's
a lot of good information to on there
because you could unless also good way
to support when you get the books The
Jackal sometimes reviews on this podcast
I organized or we organized them on
jockle podcast click on
topsis books from the from the episode I
got all the books listed there including
little articles that you know how
sometimes you'll cover article those on
there too how much research would you
have to do if you knew nothing about
this podcast or me how much research
would you have to do to figure out that
we read books on the podcast and that
they're all on Jaakko podcast.com the
reason I ask this is because I've had
I've had people ask me on social media
like a week ago like on Twitter like do
you like to read Yeah right like that's
a great for you don't have to dig very
deep to know that answer
yeah right do you like to read mmm right
that this is a really low level question
that doesn't take a whole lot of
research to figure out yeah right yeah I
guess is that laziness or is it like hey
this guy seems pretty accessible I'm
just gonna ask him here he is and what
if this guy likes to read I don't think
the likelihood of it being laziness
because obviously gonna be different for
different people but the the likelihood
of it being laziness is pretty low I
think I don't think it's lazy laziness
at all
I think it would be a mix or one of
these things yeah they just want to ask
you a question that that you know that
you're gonna have an answer to yeah or
or maybe they're just new or maybe they
know you from extreme ownership and you
know I know you wrote this cool book hey
do you like to read in general kind of
yeah maybe they listen to you're being
too harsh being too judgmental and or if
you if you jump into that conclusion
that it's laziness yeah dumb question
you like to read like we literally have
a podcast about books that we read yeah
and and then people say do you have a
list of books do you reckon you have any
books you recommend yeah do you have a
book list do you have a reading list
these are all things I get asked on a
regular basis is is this kind of like
the time I ask you hate you know end of
any gun ranges
I said yeah Google go on Google and
search nunneries yeah yeah like that
yeah yeah
yeah yeah I feel same home here's the
thing you never gonna really know when
people are coming in the game you don't
know what you know what their deal is or
where they're coming from so yeah like
maybe over mamie maybe they just heard
you on Tim Ferriss or Joe Rogan and it
was like boom this guy's super
interesting let me go straight to him
and start talking on kind of thing or
start asking questions rather than going
on the internet let me research who this
guy is and what he likes and doesn't
like to do at cetera am i am i lazy in
the fact that when I want to know
something
I'll google it no that's not easy okay I
don't yeah I don't think so as opposed
to what I don't know saying going to
school and studying at first you know
alternative nonetheless if you were
feeling not lazy actually this has
nothing to explain this because this is
more a convenience that I think would be
benefit or I thought would be beneficial
for people we're looking for the books
that you cover and ways to get them
that's why I organize these books on
talked about yeah Socko yeah the website
they're all there they're all there by
and by chance they're kind of an order
of preference in order of the way you
almost the way you should read them
maybe I'd have to shift some of them now
yeah I should put them in a different
order because there's some books that I
read again I was like manage this should
be it this should be near the top I mean
about faces the number is number one
right you should read that book first
yeah people ask me that all time well
what what's your favorite I've already
read extreme ownership is there another
book you recommend I read well and I've
read all your books what book should I
read next about face by colonel david
hackworth yeah that's like you mind one
yeah so anyways yeah makes sense I mean
I organize them by episode yeah yeah no
recent episode right with book but if
you go back to Episode one which there's
no book but - there's a book and if you
go in that order of reading that's a
good progression to get books properly
and soon soon gotcha so if you if you if
you want to read your book Jacko's book
list in order of importance in order
importance you go in chronological order
per pod casts with books that's records
and not all pod casts of books that's
right i melted cool
well there it is again just click on the
books and boom takes you there boom
click through there get your book easy
with a good way to support takes you to
Amazon all good continue shopping if you
feel the need to like if you're starving
for Valentine's Day
now that already past what's the next
one Easter mmm carry on Easter gifts
sure good those chocolate Easter bunnies
and the eggs you know you you go Easter
egg hunting right yeah yeah yeah well my
kids do sure
well my youngest kid does yeah there you
go my Falcon here yeah yeah makes sense
you know they're older after a while you
kind of figure it out kind of still fun
though
candy nonetheless click through that's
good way to support also subscribe to
the podcast if you haven't already leave
a review if you're in the mood leave a
review here's the thing I'm not saying
hey leave a review I'm not saying to
leave a review but I think sometimes
people they want to leave a review but
they don't like think about it you know
and then one let's say I get reminded
like oh should I want to leave a review
and I get reminded like boom that I'm
gonna leave a review that's a good one
I read all the reviews yeah and I read
them on the podcast before when they're
really funny or I've quoted them on
social need yeah so there's that too
yeah yeah if you write an awesome review
well it doesn't have to be awesome but
if it's funny or is good or it's
creative what's that that's what I
should have said it is a creative review
there's been some really good ones
anything with Amazon reviews for tea and
books and well yeah there's a lot of
people that get after they get colorful
for sure only colorful they put late the
main thing is lay your layers put a lot
of layers yeah yeah that's some people
real good at the layers very impressed
with that on many levels I see what you
did nonetheless subscribe if you you
know you want support that way that's a
good way thanks for the people who have
subscribed that's that's that's a good
good deal it's much appreciated big deal
also in YouTube subscribe to that if you
want if you like the video version of
this podcast or if you want watch and/or
share excerpts of this podcast three
minutes one minute sometimes
you haven't made any one minute one six
minutes sometimes you should face
someone minute once okay that'd be good
the one you just made is good thanks the
time is running out yeah that's like a
woody cold did we settle on enhanced
enhance I think it's called enhance
excerpt enhance excerpt which means that
echo has gone and put his cinematic
Flair no I would say I put some music on
it and I put some text on it there it is
- CNET's it's enhanced a little bit
that's automatic flare there yeah
alright well there it is there's some of
those on there that video as well by the
way no big deal when I got to the gym
today Carl he's okay ago yeah Carl he
says hey I saw you on worldstar straight
up popular culture yeah popular culture
we're on worldstar worldstar if you
don't know worldstar is it originally
was for fights that's what I knew it for
yeah that's how I think that's how it
gained yeah I think it just wraps it was
for ills for like music videos I think
music videos and stuff like that then
you get you know I Yusef I would watch
it because they because people would
film street fights and watch street
fights should learn a lot from street
fights and what's funny is it became
such a popular culture thing that when
people would be recording the fights
that they're gonna then put on worldstar
they would be saying worldstar after
yeah during the fight someone be filming
and saying worldstar that's going on
worldstar yeah well now guess what's on
worldstar at those videos we made it
star that's good nonetheless
yes cultural boundaries yeah hey
worldstar worldstar make it happen
hundred percent but yeah YouTube you
know so far what people are thanks for
put me on there yeah it was good that is
good awesome so yeah YouTube a good one
good way to support also chuck was a
store it's called Jacko's store
obviously chuckle store calm obviously
that's where you can get shirts t-shirts
some travel mugs on there some rash
guard
more rash guards this is like Jocko gear
rash guards so compared to how would you
compare them to the origin because
actually they're made of Energon yeah
they're similar they're you know they're
more like geared toward light toward
like Jocko well let's have yeah let's
say this that from a from a visual
perspective there's a way that Jocko
gear looks mm-hmm and there's a way that
origin gear looks you know there's some
areas that overlap mm-hmm there's some
areas that don't overlap over there some
of the let's call them color
combinations that my brother Pete
Roberts puts together they won't be
allowed in the Jacko's store yeah jagir
okay and there's some things that Jocko
gear does that wouldn't be appropriate
for origin because origin is a little
bit in the other direction sure the
overlapping areas all good yeah but if
you want your gear made in America
there's one place to get it done right
that's our factory up in Maine
true story so yeah well making it rash
guards there as well some patches
those are restocked a lot of people were
heating me up this life for patches yeah
it's weird that people have to hit you
up that you just don't pay attention to
the stock and say well what running low
I should he order more yeah yeah it's
not that important to you no no no
that's important so I got a handle on it
and I think I have a solid system where
you know we're gonna run into way less
of that if any of that okay unless some
women's stuff on there some hats cuz it
does mean a lot to me yeah just I'm
saying
that's cool so maybe I should be more I
should do a better job of expressing how
important it is to me for people if they
want patches to be able to get one yeah
maybe I haven't I obviously haven't done
a good job yeah it's your fault it's
your fault
it is so yeah chocolate or calm that's
good good good way to support also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is that's an album an album
not a music album it's a to joking word
spoken word with tracks chocolate tracks
and each track is designated formulated
engineered it's engineered is what it is
to help you through little points of
weakness that you might run into on your
campaign against weakness like you know
you want to skip ice I always say if you
want to skip the workout if you're like
hey I'm too tired I don't feel like it I
don't feel like it I start with that one
because that's essentially why this
whole thing exists because that does the
issue that was the genesis of this album
yeah was echo questioning how he could
overcome these moments of weakness or
how I do in the night kind of answered
one of them and he said we do record
those things yeah you know what's funny
is that I asked you that before and it
wasn't that specific question but it was
essentially that question and be like eh
what do you do and then you look he kind
of gave me a look and more like as if
your feelings don't matter kind of thing
you'd basically pull the jaw can also
add a I got asked this similar you know
someone said hey Joe can you tell us a
little bit more about your morning
routine like what you could soon you
know you can I know you get up early but
can you tell us more about your morning
which he knows idea listen my morning
routine is extremely extremely important
so here's here's the steps of the jockle
morning routine first of all you set
your alarm clock you said all your alarm
clocks you set the first one at 4:30 you
set the next one at 4:35 you set the
next one at 4:40 and you have your
backups mmm
by the way you don't set your backups at
the same time cuz you want to be
fumbling around with three alarm clocks
and ioniq it's good tip I said then you
get done with that then when the alarm
clock goes off you get up you get out of
bed then you go and it's important that
you get your toothbrush out in that
brush and then I use it 46 brush strokes
on each side of my mouth
and no more no less
and then I spit three times I'm like oh
yeah here's the morning routine dude you
get up and you go yeah yeah well then
again no I know right yeah yeah I know
but it's like the reality is is someone
gonna write down my morning routine then
follow the exact same thing and would
that be good for him maybe I don't know
well here's another morning routine then
get up and go get up and get yeah
but here's like some people they they
they focus on and this can be beneficial
from from what I hear they focus on or
they identify certain things they do in
a morning routine that helps them that
like set some up my morning routine and
I actually wrote about in the in the
field manual it's like more the morning
routine starts the night before yeah
yeah the morning routine starts when you
get your gear ready because you want to
be fumbling around in the morning don't
wait don't set yourself up to fumble
around with things in the morning right
that's just a bad thing don't do that so
you you do you have your gear ready you
know for me I'm a I'm very systematic in
pretty much yeah the way big and but you
know I have like all my workout gear is
in the bathroom on hangers you know pair
of shorts shirt on each hanger six of
them they're all the same there's no
fault process that's needed they're all
matching and I have the same kind of
socks all my socks are the same I do
have black socks and white socks but the
one drawer is just completely white
socks all the same you grab those you
put those on boom you brush your teeth
boom you take I take my supplements in
the morning and at night but I take my
like royal in my my joint warfare boom
and then I go hit it how much water
teaching it's it's I drink what I'm
thirsty I drink and then if I measure it
you know you don't be like okay no makes
it okay I think I drink I'm thirsty are
you when I'm hungry
but if you drink water when you're
thirsty you're already two percent
dehydrated okay well I drink I drink
about three percent more than so you one
percent over over hydrated or hydrated
then unless but well you know like I'll
drink a whole thing like the you know
the mug that we have a child there's
three ounces by the way I'll drink a
whole thing of that just routine that's
kind of the routine but was like in the
morning yeah you pound it sure if you
want to call it pound I can do you think
it because you want to stay hydrated
yeah but get the water back in there man
get get it okay that's good for you
water is good for you by the way yeah no
doubt better than soda in the morning
you recheck a coke in the morning no bro
it's a worse
did these monster masses in back in the
d'oeuvres and somewhat a son was doing a
Monster Mash with us when he was like 6
or let the Monster Mash is like yo you
do rope climbs that you do is sprint ok
workout swim and then you do pull-ups in
the U and they put little things in
there sometimes so one of the things
that they had to do was drink a coke
through a straw so you're like doing
pull-ups in a row Prime in the coke yeah
and so he he I think that was the first
time you ever tried soda yeah nasty it's
well there's your wanting soda though
yeah
the there's two elements to drinking a
soda special for the first time is okay
tastes weird sweet sugary and carbonated
yeah the carbonation will burn your
money it feels like it's burning your
mouth yeah she's all like it yeah you
can't do that you could that's not
writing them another workout too sure
couldn't do that well you keep in mind
you just described your morning routine
you know the question that they're I
know the answer that's why I said look
I'm not trying to be negative against
morning routines yeah and there's pretty
much what I do but the the reason is I
think people think oh if I have if I
knew your morning routine then I'd know
what the secret is yes oh yeah hey man
the secret is get up and go do something
that's a secret yeah I'm not gonna say
here's the deal here's the deal I'm not
gonna sell you my morning routine and
the solution to your problem
now I will say that if you fumble around
in the morning it's gonna cause you
problems throughout the day so don't
fumble around the morning set your set
your life up correctly so that you're
not fumbling around that's good
I'm not gonna sell you my morning
routine as the solution to your problems
yes I'm not gonna do that but I will say
that if you do have a good system that
you go through in the morning it will
set up your day correctly yeah that's
why I think people and I get it okay so
I'm not trying to be like a jerk right
I'm not ready that negative I guess I'm
kind of making live well you making fun
making fun of morning routines a little
bit but at the same time I have one a
night and I stick to it yeah but I think
the things that's the thing I don't I
don't actually have something and I
stick to it like I do this is what is I
follow the functional thing that works
and you stick to it yeah and I stick to
it so that's
but I do I didn't like design my morning
routine yeah yeah I didn't see no it's
like I know what works it's functional
and that's what I do I do things that
work okay not everyone figured out on
their own what works
I just here's the thing your morning
routine you're you're ultimately right
and I think this is the it's super
important not to forget or not to like
miss interpret where you know you just
uh that quote you just said like good
morning routines not gonna be the
solution to your problems kind of thing
I think that's what people do think I
think that here someone with a level
head in my opinion I don't I don't know
but this is what it seems like where
someone with a level head and they want
to look for just that justice just that
one thing that's gonna help them just a
little bit you know so they're gonna be
like hey let me let me formulate a good
morning routine I don't know that much
about effective routines so let me look
into that just says a little helper not
the solution to my problems which I
think some people may kind of miss no
you're right and that's right like I
said I'm not belittling the idea that a
morning routine is helpful because it
certainly is yeah it might add some some
tiny bit of help to your day and some
that you're doing the right thing
there's some benefits thank you it might
benefit your day which is positive will
it cure your overall problems of life no
but you know what it's a good place to
start that's why we say wake up early
right yeah that's part of the part of
the part of the routine so yeah but even
how you I guess I am being a jerk yeah
but here's the thing
let me just like yeah get on a good
morning routine that's a good idea
I like it yeah yeah I'm not trying to
make fun of it I I was but I'm not
anymore it seems like you're making fun
of it for people cuz this is what it
maybe sounded like when someone asks you
what's your morning routine it sounds
like you you're kind of with this
presumption like you're presuming or
assuming that they think it's gonna
solve all their problems that's right
yeah yes but in that very specific
direction like if someone says hey look
I'm always looking for things to benefit
my day my effectiveness
you know I've you know I do this and do
that and I found that this even helps a
little bit here and there hey what's
your
maybe I can incorporate one or more
maybe into mine
that'll give me a little bit of help too
I don't think you would've came out like
you know awfully that would have been a
very good question oh yeah here's what I
do
yeah there you go so you can how you my
said the question like you were kind of
impersonating yeah yeah yes sorry sorry
sorry everyone
no person you know the bottom of it you
know you drinking water another drink
you can drink is you can drink something
called jockle white tea sure it's
available in Amazon now this is the only
tea available not only in America but in
the world that comes within 8,000 pound
deadlift guarantee so there's no other
tea I know there's some out there that
are better they say 6,000 they say they
can get you 6,000 pound deadlift yeah
there's I've seen I've seen 7,200 right
you see the 72 some teas some what some
white teas say they'll get you 7,200
there's only one white tea that'll get
you the guaranteed 8,000 pound deadlift
good there's some layers on the tea
which I kind of remembered last time I
didn't wanna interrupt interrupt you you
um you talking is first episode of this
podcast absolute first one oh yeah I
think the only one that doesn't start
with this is the Junko podcast that's
because you had a different vision of
the nonetheless it started with you and
I think of this podcast is be a hundred
percent it felt like that first one
that's what it felt like ya know in your
mind yeah in my mind if you listen yeah
now you could see I was not I was not
ready to cruise yeah I came in there
with a game plan yes and the game plan
did not say cruise on it but said get
after those funnies you shut it down so
quick great when you heard it you're
like you know you want to cut it at this
point not the not the the little car
like we just rolled into a conversation
yeah but here's the thing with that
conversation as far as the layers go we
talked about white tee yeah you call it
a chai ya know cuz I was trying to
remember what kind of tea that was I
don't know about the tea especially back
then
nonetheless you were always on the
pomegranate yeah I guess that started
when I was in the dirt oh wow that's oh
so anyways you can get that you can get
it on Amazon and then you can start
deadlifting properly yeah there's some
books that you can get way the warrior
kid I get questions all the time about
how you should raise your kids and and
and and not just how to raise them cuz
any people know how to raise them but
they not how to raise them but how to
raise them like they know what they want
the kids to they know the values that
they want the kids to have but they're
not sure how to give them the values
right they don't know how to do that so
it real simple get them this book way of
the warrior kid that that's you know
discipline eating habits working out
dealing with bullies how to study all
those things are in there these are the
things you want not just your kid but
the children of the world to have these
type of qualities and now on top of that
we have way the warrior kid to which is
called Mark's mission talks about some
important lessons controlling your
temper overcoming fear of failure
working hard
saving money being frugal dealing with
verbal abuse helping other people
starting businesses yeah I said that mmm
and becoming a leader again all the
there's no human being that would look
at the lessons from way of the warrior
kid and said it would say I don't want
my kid to have that quality know the
qualities are in there so there's that
and if you want a good example of a
warrior kid
check out Irish Oaks ranch calm or you
can get soap that's a handmade by young
Aiden who's 12 years old but he has a
business no big deal he's making soap
you know well they don't think goat milk
soap yeah that soaps actually good like
to use so first let's face it you know
how you have your friend and his wife
make you sympathy purchase scenario
you know and you clean and it's a
beautiful it has the little packaging
and then you say alright it's soap let
me go ahead and use some soap in here
like Brad this isn't like usable soap
this is the novelty decorative item it
was a cool little educational experience
cuz he asked me you know he was making
soap and he's and he reached out to me
his dad is a farmer also a firefighter
produced a farmer anyways his dad and I
were connected I buy meat from his dad
and you know he said oh my son wants to
get in touch with you but so as we're
going through the process he sends me
like his label for the soap yeah and you
know it looked nice but um it went back
with no this needs to be an OCR standard
yeah so anyway so yeah it's cool little
learning process and yeah you can get
that soap you can support a kid that's a
warrior kid and the Jacko's soap motto
which I give Aiden no credit for
sorry eighty and you're a good kid but
you didn't think of this it took the it
took the masterful marketing mind of
Jocko to come up with the motto for
Jacko's soap which is stay clean
it's good and you know there's some
layers on that too right like yeah
mostly Motorhead song all right there
you go and you like Motorhead and I am a
huge fan of Motorhead and you don't do
any drugs so there's they're kind of
that the reason that whenever I talk to
people or people talk to me on through
social media or email and they've had a
drug problem or an alcohol problem and I
always kind of sign off like hey stay
clean stay clean so because that's also
what Lemmy from Motorhead was saying
stay clean like don't let this kill you
now lemme from Motorhead was a rare dude
who did a lot of drugs and alcohol and
somehow was able to survive very well up
to up to when he died drinking
incredible amounts of Jack Daniels yeah
those are some legit layers but he
always would say don't do it yeah he's a
guy that would say don't do it it's
don't do it don't do what people do
don't do drugs
yeah stay clean stay clean there you go
in addition to that got another book
called the discipline ich
freedom field manual and if this is this
is a good point if you know someone
that's off the path right like people go
off the path in life and it doesn't take
we talked about this last if it doesn't
take but one step off the path when
you're on a slippery slope yeah it's a
slippery slope when you step off the
path so if you know someone that has
taken a step off the path and they're
starting to slide down get them this
book to get them on the path the right
path and there's also a chance that the
person that stepped off the path is you
so get the Field Manual it's got the
thoughts and actions that are required
to be on the right path make yourself
better faster stronger smarter anything
else more physically fit and healthier
the audio version that is on iTunes
Amazon music google play other mp3
platforms it's not on audible because
then you can't have it as an album with
tracks which we obviously support
extreme ownership first book I wrote
with my brother Leif babban over a
million copies sold
that's a lot of copies sold yes that's a
lot of copies sold you know how many
copies they told us would be successful
because we didn't know anything laughs
and I didn't know anything about the
publishing world wait what do you mean
it when we were getting when the book
was getting ready to come out and I
would talk to the pool we were talking
to publisher laughs and I were talking
to the publisher and he says you know if
this is a successful book then you know
and it'll really be it'll be good to see
blah blah blah that's like the standard
like admit like a certain amount that's
the Sun you know so I said hey what hey
I don't know anything about this what is
considered to be a successful work you
know what the number was twenty thousand
books dang he goes and you know if he
goes hey you know we're we're printing
twelve thousand on this first run and if
you sell if you will print some more but
if you can sell 20,000 books that's
that's gonna be that's a huge success
and yeah he will be proud so here we are
were 1 million
it's pretty cool yeah good job life
babban good job yeah
life life tells a story that we got home
from Ramadi and the only time I ever
told him anything positive was when we
got home moving home for like two weeks
and I told him in the Delta platoon
commander hey good job over there so
yeah we're Kiwi I likes to keep it real
yeah man and actually you know what the
good job over there seems real simple
but I'm sure in that context it was
probably the most loaded yeah good job
anyone's ever heard yeah yeah I believe
you're correct beyond the books and
beyond the podcast also national on
fronts speaking away from me this is our
leadership and management consulting
company this is the thing every this is
a bold statement right every problem in
every organization is leadership problem
that's a bold statement to make
yeah and I'll say it again every problem
in every organization is a leadership
problem so if there's a problem in an
organization the problem it boils down
to leadership on some level so what we
do is we fix the leadership and thereby
we fix your problems it's me it's Lafe
Babb and it's JP Danelle it's Dave Burke
good deal Dave Burke until Dave if you
want to get in touch with us to have us
come out and work with your company get
your leadership aligned go to info at
Ashkelon front comm or you email info
Nichelle on front comm or you can go to
the website as long front comm and of
course we are approaching the muster the
leadership seminar learn you learn
tactics of leadership you learn
strategies of leadership you learn
pragmatic techniques you can execute as
a leader that will make you and your
team win
we already expanded the floor so we
expanded the floor as much as we could
already because the the ticket sales are
going quickly and so we've got both
places that we're doing the muster we've
and expand it as much as we can doesn't
matter they're both both of they're
going to sell out doing two this year
only Washington DC May 17th and 18th and
San Francisco October 17th and 18th the
whole team will be there and we will be
with you if you come we'll be hanging
out we'll be answering questions we'll
be talking we'll be eating lunch we'll
be we'll be hanging out working out with
all of you that come there's no green
room
there's no backstage where where life is
sitting back there in the backstage with
cucumbers on his eyes to relax that's
not happening no no we're hanging out
all of us so you can register for that
at extreme ownership calm we'll see you
there and until the muster you can find
us by interacting and conversing and
cruising with us on the interwebs on
Twitter on Instagram and on that phase
II blah
echo is at echo Charles and I am at
Jocko Willington once again Dan Crenshaw
is at Crenshaw for congress.com his
Twitter's at Dan Crenshaw TX and his
Facebook is Dan Crenshaw and like to
thank everyone for listening thanks to
all the men and women in uniform across
the globe with sword in hand and heart
at the ready to fight and die for what
we hold sacred and to police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics and
all first responders thanks for being
prepared and thanks for being there when
we call you in our time of need and to
everyone else out there thank you for
listening and thank you for sharing and
thank you for supporting but more
important thanks for finding your
mission and executing your mission
whether it's your job or your business
or a charity or your family or whatever
for your mission is thanks for getting
out there and getting after it so until
next time this is Dan Crenshaw and echo
and Jocko out